alors j'ai entendu dire que ici il y
avait plusieurs personnes qui allaient
être diplômés alors bravo tout d'abord
bravo parce que vous avez appris plein
de choses d'un savoir théorique
ici vous êtes et des apprentissages des
stages vous avez comme une belle
formation et bravo pour ça et donc on
peut se dire qu'avec un tel bagage un
tel diplôme pour vous c'est un peu la
réussite assurée c'est à dire que vous
aurez une belle maison une famille des
amis et c'est tout ira bien et c'est ce
que je pensais moi aussi à l'époque
quand j'étais ça remonte à une dizaine
d'années quand même quand j'étais
étudiant sortie de mon diplôme sortie
avec mon diplôme je pensais que c'était
un sésame pour la suite et là stop
est-ce que c'est suffisant évidemment
vous connaissez la réponse derrière
sinon je serais pas en train de vous
faire un taux qui si vous verrez qu'avec
le temps le diplôme c'est ce qu'il ya de
moins en moins ça ça s'appelle
d'importance finalement il ya d'autres
choses qui arrivent ya des autodidactes
qui sont qui ont un grand succès ils ont
pas fait mine de charbon pourtant ça
veut dire qu'il ya d'autres forces et il
y en a une qui est au dessus de toutes
les autres que j'ai pris du temps à
apprendre et cette force
elle n'est pas enseignée à l'école et
cette force j'aurais bien aimé moi ya
dix ans qu'on puisse me l'enseigné
ça s'appelle la force de votre réseau
alors un réseau qu'est ce que c'est un
réseau tout simplement
c'est des gens qui penseront à vous et
qui vous aideront quand vous en aurez
besoin voire même parfois qui viendront
au devant de vos besoins
donc c'est plutôt agréable et
concrètement ce que ça permet de faire
ça va permettre ça vous permettent de
démultiplier votre puissance alors je
sais comment ça se voit clairement sympa
mais un réseau moi j'ai 24 ans j'en ai
j'en ai pas en fait vous trompez vous
trompez pas ce qu à 24 ans déjà alors
vous comment vous pensez à vos camarades
de promotion des personnes qui ont le
même âge que vous alors oui ils font
partie de votre réseau je crois que vous
êtes des promos de 400 personnes c'est
énorme comme réseau déjà en plus
j'imagine que l'été vous partez en
vacances avec des amis
tout cela tous ces gens qui vont évoluer
avec vous
qui dans 10 ou 15 ans seront des grands
directeurs comme vous des grands sillons
comme vous font partie de votre réseau
et ensuite finalement 1 reste un réseau
ça ressemble un peu à ça c'est à dire
qu'au début c'est rien on voit un grand
trou noir mais en fait un réseau
c'est un peu comme une galaxie est en
fait une galaxie quand on creuse dans la
galaxie on commence à se rendre compte
en fait une myriade de choses qu'on
avait qu'on ne soupçonnait pas
auparavant et qu'en fait cas des groupes
de personnes fait peut-être au de
l'insee a évidemment mais vous avez
peut-être un fait du sport peut-être ou
peut-être vous avez vos amis d'enfance
et tous ces groupes là en fait sont des
groupes qui sont liés entre eux mais à
quelque chose d'encore plus intéressant
c'est qu'en fait entre les groupes
parfois il les connecteurs et c'est là
toute la puissance du réseau finalement
parce que si on zoome bien jusqu'au bout
finalement une personne en connaît
d'autres en connaît d'autres en connaît
d'autres et finalement votre réseau est
vraiment très très étendue beaucoup plus
que vous ne pouviez l'imaginer actuelle
et les réseaux en fait c'est tout bête
hein ça pourrait être n'importe quelle
personne que vous croisez je me souvient
la tante ursule à du canada je la
connais pas mais en fait finalement est
là elle connaît plein de personnes qui
pourraient qui pourrait me donner un
coup de main et elle serait très content
de pouvoir donner un coup de main ça
peut être n'importe quoi votre prof de
dessin ça pourrait être pourquoi pas
mettre votre propriétaire si vous êtes
locataire moi ça m'est arrivé dans
l'autre sens et marans et j'ai aidé mon
propriétaire à trouver un logement dans
le sud de la france parce qu'il
cherchait à se loger à côté de chez mes
parents
il n'y a que des hasards mais c'est ça
qui est sympa et même même votre médecin
généraliste
mon médecin généraliste m'a aidé à avoir
un travail tout simplement parce que
lorsqu'il me le soigne et on a discuté
et je lui ai expliqué que j'étais en
train de rechercher un job et manivet
attends je suis en train de moi je
soigne tous les lundis 7 7 drh de ce
très grand groupe
tiens c'est marrant et donc donne moi
ton cv voilà donc le cv parti je n'y
suis pas allé finalement pour ce qui
regarde les surligner et c'est donc non
vous ne trouvez pas cette race là est ce
que je veux faire aujourd'hui moi c'est
vous partager trois conseils trois
conseils et je vais vous faire un cadeau
aussi c'est qu'à la fin je vais vous
donner un moyen mnémotechnique qui vous
permettra encore dans dix ans
vous souvenir de ses trois conseils le
premier conseil premièrement agrandissez
le agrandissez le réseau il faut pas
perdre une occasion tout s'est à chaque
fois en tout lieu mais c'est également
tout le temps et si j'ai un seul conseil
à vous donner un seul cas son conseil à
vous donner c'est enlève tes écouteurs
bien sûr avec des écouteurs êtes dans
votre bulle ne parlait pas aux gens
enlève tes écouteurs ouvre tes yeux
ouvre la bouche et vous connaissez
finalement qu'elle est noire le meilleur
moyen pour que quelqu'un vous parle
c'est tout simplement de lui parler donc
commencer et pour ça souvent certaines
personnes sont surprises délires vouloir
parler d'un god qu'est ce que tu me
c'est la première démarche mais si vous
êtes honnête sincère et souriant
finalement tout va bien c'est qu'est ce
que tu veux non je veux simplement te
connaître c'est tout a pas dans ce
cas-là allons-y et bonne nouvelle
parler de soi c'est souvent le sujet
conversation préféré les gens donc ça
marchera bien et finalement il ya aussi
souvent cette phrase qui vient mais la
première phrase qu'est ce que je dis en
fait en premier et en fait c'est pas
grave la première phrase vous pouvez
dire quelque chose de stupide
par exemple moi j'avais fait j'avais
fait en nba aux états unis et je
trouvais pas de travail et un jour je me
suis retrouvé par hasard s'il ya des
condominiums là bas avec plein
appartements qui se partagent un centre
sportif je me suis retrouvé dans un
jacuzzi
je pense que j'ai dit une chose stupide
comme à l'eau est froide où l'eau est
chaude je sais plus exactement mais en
fait il s'avérait qu'ils avaient une
personne qui était là je m'adresse à
elle forcément que je connaissais pas
qui m'a dit on a commencé à engager la
conversation
il a remarqué un accent médias c'est
marrant tu as un accent tu viens d'où je
viens de france il ya c'est marrant moi
je travaille dans cette grosse grosse
entreprise et on a plein de gens qui ont
fait des milliers qui sont de partout
dans le monde le lendemain j'ai passé
six heures d'entretiens dans cette
société
ils m'ont offert un job à la fin plutôt
pratique
l'eau est bonne
vous pouvez faire également si vous
pouvez utiliser un contexte imaginons je
ne sais pas si vous allez au théâtre des
tout bête alors je sais que certains
d'entre vous cherche des stages
voilà il y en a pas mal qui cherchent
des stages c'est normal et à chaque fois
c'est compliqué pour le cacher on n'a
pas envie on sait pas comment faire
mais en fait aller au théâtre dans la
file d'attenté quand on peut voir cette
personnalité au théâtre tout simplement
vous vous demandez vous utiliseront le
contexte parler aux gens qui sont devant
vous pour leur dire et vous en faites
qu'est-ce qui vous emmène ici la
personne va vous répondre et très
probablement pas vous dire on va vous
retourne la question et vous dans ce cas
là à vous d'être un peu habile écoutez
moi c'est très simple je vais passer ma
journée sans ma recherche de stage
franchement à fond et la gemme vider
l'esprit au théâtre ce qui est certain
c'est que si cette personne connaît
quelqu'un qui cherche un stagiaire c'est
pour vous donc allez au diable
il n'y a pas de fin pour trouver ces
premiers sujets de conversation par
exemple n'importe quel objet peut
fonctionner en bas un casque ou le la
personne qui est là qu un vélo vous avez
un joli vélo la personne parlera de son
vélo si c'est un fixie c'est encore
mieux les gens sont fans de leur fixe y
met un casque ça marche aussi dans une
moto oui oui j'ai telle moto ça marche
c'est parti je sais pas si vous savez ce
qu'est la deuxième paie cette image là
bas à droite
voilà c'est une rosette c'est la rose
aides régionales et plus
particulièrement c'est le grade de
commandeur ce qu'on voit qu'un pavillon
blanc voilà bon on est dans le cliché
mais ce qui est certain c'est que les
gens qui arbore une légion d'honneur en
fait qu'est ce que c'est c'est tout
simplement un appel à la conversation
s'est parlé est ce que vous pourriez me
poser la question de ce que j'ai sur moi
demandez moi pourquoi je mérite cette
légion d'honneur
et là vous êtes parti pour une belle
conférence certainement intéressante en
plus il ya un double avantage en plus
d'être la personne vu vous avez repéré
qu'elle avait une légion d'honneur en
plus le grade vous considérera vous
mettra quasiment à sa hauteur vous dire
qu on est du même monde
voilà donc le stage derrière cet opus
il ya aussi un autre signe mais en des
exemples une athlète hors la semaine
dernière la bague en or lé avec un x
dessus moi j'étais j'ai fait un échange
universitaire au canada et en fait
chaque diplômé avec cette bague sortait
que cette bague on les aime ou on n'aime
pas en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est
que c'est la fierté des étudiants ils la
gardent toute leur vie la semaine
dernière dans le sud de la france
j'étais dans un train une personne à
cette vague
j'ai eu 10 1 et en plus sur la bague a
marqué l'année de diplômes d'abord mais
vous étiez à saint francis xavier 1 en
2003 la zone s'est retournée en me
disant viens tu connais saint francis
xavier
oui j'ai étudié pendant un an c'est du
velours derrière voilà donc il ya plein
de choses
plein de signes distinctifs mettez-vous
également en situation
par exemple moi quand je prends le train
si pour quelques euros de plus je peux
voir une première classe et bien
évidemment jean première classe et
qu'est ce que je choisis comme fauteuil
surtout pas la place isoler la place il
ya deux personnes encore mieux à 4
pourquoi parce que je me garantit
d'avoir certainement des gens avec qui
discuter et je suis pas à l'abri d'avoir
des gens ultra intéressant
voilà donc ouvrir et en plus le deuxième
le deuxième quant au conseil que je peux
vous donner c'est chercher pourquoi
parce qu'en fait dans chaque personne il
ya un trésor toujours toujours toujours
et si vous n'avez pas trouver ce trésor
ce n'est pas poser les bonnes questions
continuent à chercher ils vous auraient
de l'information et en plus il ya un
effet ultra magique derrière ma logique
derrière il se passera deux choses
premièrement vous allez mieux connaître
la personne tout d'un coup trouver des
points communs avec cette personne qui
était un inconnu auparavant trouvé des
choses exceptionnelles et que cette
personne est donc finalement vous
commencerez à l'apprécier il ya un
deuxième effet qu'en plus sympa c'est
que étant donné que vous l'appréciez
votre le langage corporel montre que
vous avez bien cette personne cette
personne vous à mon retour
donc c'est fabuleux tout d'un coup les
gens vous aiment parce que vous l'aurez
poser une question
ce qu'on dit concrètement c'est
intéressez vous aux gens pour que les
gens s'intéressent à vous
et dans ce cas là souvent quand les gens
vous ont parlé un petit peu de leur vie
qu'ils vont se passer c'est qu'ils vont
s'intéresse à vous poser une question
balla soyez intelligent quand même
préparer votre réponse parce que la
personne n'aura n'a pas de mémoire
infinie dire essayer de garder une
réponse concise en donnant un deux ou
trois mots clés mais deux maximum 1
c'est ya pas mal pour que la personne se
souvienne de vous moi par exemple mon
mot clé quand j'étais jeune c'était
l'aviron parce que je faisais de
l'aviron à haute dose ensuite ça a
évolué aujourd'hui le mot clé souvent
que je donne quand je rencontre
quelqu'un c'est brigitte le nom de ma
société
pourquoi parce que si vous allez sur
linkedin et vous tapez vincent bernard
vous avez 406 réponse good luck ont
retrouvé en revanche vincent bernard
brigitte ça ça marche
et en plus je plaisante dessus en disant
mais appelez moi brigitte et quand je
marche dans la rue les parkings brigitte
brigitte je me retourne parfois c'est
pour moi voilà donc tout ça c'est bien
sympa vous avez réussi à engager la
conversation vous cherchez des choses
chez les gens et vous laisser un
souvenir en plus indélébile chez les
gens c'est bien mais tout ça serait une
perte de temps s'il n'avait pas le
deuxième conseil et ce deuxième conseil
c'est tout simplement la tirelire c'est
à dire conserver cette information
précieusement capitaliser sur cette
information
et je vais vous aider en fait il ya
certaines personnes pour capter se
capitaliser sur l'information ne peut
pas tout retenir s'il ya une seule chose
que je vais retenir sur une personne
qu'est ce que c'est
un seul mot le mot clé où il c'est vrai
pourquoi pas mais un mot encore plus
fort son prénom évidemment son prénom de
pub zbb c'est le mot vous entendez le
plus et en plus c'est vos parents qui
vous en parle avec des mots chargés
d'amour donc quoi de plus agréable que
d'appeler une personne par son prénom
regarder ce beau sourire on se souvient
de son prénom c'est parfait pour ça il
ya plein de technique il ya des gens
qu'on excellente mémoire et cetera
mais au bout d'un moment
la technique c'est bien mais ça devient
limité vous savez que il ya 150 millions
de personnes dans le monde qui ont plus
de 1000 connexions sur linkedin
alors ils peuvent avoir des techniques
de mémorisation ça venir compliquer au
bout d'un moment c'est pour ça qu'en
fait il existe d'autres techniques moi
je connais des j'ai interviewé beaucoup
de networker est en fait ils ont chacun
leur technique papier ils ont des
supports papier téléphone feuille excel
ou autres où il rentre des choses et
qu'est-ce qu'il rentre à l'intérieur il
rentre souvent ces choses là qui sont
tout simplement le prénom de la personne
un contact par quelque intermédiaire et
nous rencontrer dans quelles
circonstances et des mots clés c'est
important mais les meilleurs les
ceintures noires de networking qu'est ce
qu'ils font il rajoute encore une chose
ce qui rajoute dessus c'est un élément
d'action et l'action ça peut être
quelque chose de tout bête juste prendre
des nouvelles organisé un café présenter
quelqu'un c'est tout et maintenant vient
le troisième et dernier conseil vous
êtes ouvert aux gens vous avez capté de
l'information mais encore une fois pour
passer au stade d'en haut est là pour
faire vraiment la différence
le conseil le plus important entretenez
votre réseau évidemment et pour ça en
fait est quelque chose de tout bête
c'est le pouvoir des petites attentions
c'est toutes petites choses qui font
toute la différence par exemple moi j'ai
rencontré une fois dans un salon
professionnel une personne françois qui
m'a ensuite appelé un mois de janvier
une fois pour m'appeler je me suis dit
qu'est-ce qui me veut en fait il m'a
appelé pour prendre des nouvelles
j'étais surpris bon très bien l'année
suivante mois de janvier nouveau coup de
téléphone de françois bon parfois c'est
prendre des nouvelles
il veut quelque chose certainement alors
je t'appelle pour prendre des nouvelles
très sympa et maintenant chaque fois
qu'ils m'appellent au mois de janvier je
pense à très très sympa donc finalement
tout d'un coup cette personne françois
que j'ai rencontré une fois dans ma vie
prendre deux minutes par an pour
m'appeler et je trouve sympa et fiable
pas mal vous pouvez aussi envoyer des
articles de journaux qu'ils ont porté
aux gens des photos ou un bouquin une
personne qui m'envoie une fois un
bouquin
j'ai été touché en plein coeur parce
qu'elle a pensé à moi il m'a fait un
cadeau très très très très faim me
concernant la deûle à ce que vous pouvez
faire également c'est recommandé
effectivement des personnes vous pouvez
rendre des services
moi j'ai présenté des amis qui se sont
mariés donc autant dire que ils se
rendent moins pendant longtemps
également vous avez plein de compétences
je sais pas certains d'entre vous
peut-être vous savez faire des sites
internet pour vous c'est très simple
pour des personnes c'est un enfer donc
si vous passez passé une demi-heure avec
eux vous allez leur faire un bien fou
est là pour avec certes et avec
certitude il parlant de vous en très
très bien par la suite
enfin et ce qui est important également
quand vous rendez service à tout le
monde c'est de ne rien attendre en
breton en retour sinon on fausse la
relation et c'est un cercle vertueux qui
se met en place
enfin osé demander osé demander parce
que tout simplement quand vous demandez
quelque chose à quelqu'un
souvent on hésite on n'ose pas mais en
fait en le sollicitant vous le flatter
et vous reconnaissez son pouvoir
quelques pardon n'hésitez pas à demander
de l'aide
et en plus ça ferme et gardez votre
réseau actif il a été prouvé quand vous
demandez un service à quelqu'un même si
c'est un service génial vient m'aider à
déménager à rien la fois suivante la
personne vous aidera d'autant plus
facilement voilà bon résumons vous allez
bientôt être diplômés bravo maintenant
je n'ai aucun doute pour votre réussite
parce que vous avez un atout en plus
c'est à tous il est dingue ça s'appelle
de connaître le pouvoir du networking
vous avez bien compris que les working
c'est quelque chose d'important
certains disent que c'est l'art des rois
mais dans networking il ya également
working pourquoi parce que c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne enfin je vous ai
promis un moyen mots techniques pour
vous souvenir à vis de ceux de ses trois
conseils
donc je suis pas j'ai voulu prendre un
sport j'ai pas pris l'aviron ce que je
pense que j'aurais pas rassemblé grand
monde
j'ai pris le tennis c'est ce que des
gens jouent au tennis chez vous ici
d'accord donc pas mal on voit que c'est
un sport assez populaire et finalement
être le tennis qu'elle est comment
fait-on pour gagner un match de tennis
et ben en fait c'est très simple pour
gagner un match de tennis ont fait des
coups gagnants et le meilleur coup
gagnant s'appelle un ace a nice c'est
quelque chose
qui est prêt si on saisit une
opportunité la personne est fatigué par
givet j'observais je me suis bien placé
et surtout surtout je me suis beaucoup
entraîné
donc il faut quand même s'entraîner pour
pouvoir faire des extérieurs et danthez
évidemment il ya agrandi c'est votre
réseau capitaliser sur votre réseau et
enfin entretenez le écoutez j'ai aucun
doute pour la suite pour vous excellente
réussite à tous et bonne route
[Applaudissements]